which business should I start so I got a
question for my youtube viewers Jacob
love you guys who wrote in the say wants
to start a comic book business ok and to
fund it he wants to start a business
that rents out old books and he's
writing to me to ask how do I stand out
from the libraries and the other
companies out there that are renting
books to make money so I can fund my
comic book business how do I stand out
and make this business work because of
so much competition so here's the thing
okay I get that you need to get funding
right you got to get money to launch
your business and end at the start you
got to get past survival this is the
most important part in any business you
need to get to the point of survival
survival is where you have enough money
to do your business full time and not
have to worry about going back and
getting the job or other sources of
income or capital that's survival okay
I'm not acting glamorous lifestyle I'm
not talking about renting Ferraris I'm
talking about eating okay eating
survival paying the rent survival that's
where you got to get your business the
challenge I've seen here is you've got
to really early stage ideas okay you
don't know how either them I'm going to
work out you have your comic book
business comic-book business and you've
got your renting out old books business
neither of them you don't understand how
you're going to market it you don't send
how you're going to stand out you don't
know how you're going to make money why
are you focusing your energy your
efforts your resources your time into
solving the renting the book business
when you're not passionate about that
your passion real comic books I could
understand that if this business were
further ahead if you had customers if
you were making a lot of money and you
weren't passionate about it you want to
transition the comic books you're making
a lot of money here so you're going to
keep that gravy train going to fund this
other business while while it was just
getting started but you don't know how
you're going to stand out with the
library book business either right you
haven't figured that out so why are you
spending your time on this this is that
you're not passionate about that's not
making you a lot of money when you can
put that same time and effort into
your passion boat which is the comic
books right that's where i would spend
my time as an entrepreneur especially
have to start right your I get that it's
hard right like you really want to do
this one thing you're passionate about
you want to chase your dream you want to
build something great but you don't have
enough time and money to live so you
can't focus on that business you need to
get to the point where you're spending
as much time on your business that
you're passionate about as possible and
that may mean doing something else as
another business that makes money that
may mean taking on a part-time job just
to make money to pay the bills to
survive but you have to start carving
out time to focus on that comic book
business that's where you need to spend
your energy when you're asking me a
question you're asking for help it
should be able to comic book business
how do i get my comic book business to
be amazing right that's where you got to
be focusing your mental energy and time
and resources and again i can understand
that this library book idea thing was
taken off and making a lot of money
already but it's not there yet you don't
know how it's going to work out you
don't know how you're going to stand out
and you're not passionate about that
business so forget about that business
and worry about the comic books and find
a way to survive with the comic books
when that becomes a must you start
seeing great changes in your business
believe floozy watching a video give her
a thumbs up below leave a comment let me
know you think you have a question leave
it below i'll make a video response and
i subscribe to the channel if you want
to see more videos like this thank you
guys so much and I'll see you soon